in the interview i guess where he was
pantsless i don't know
he's talking about the georgia race and
the senate race because he's wanting to
overthrow all these elections the
arizona audit and georgia and you know
just on and on and on with this dominion
machine stuff
if just just [ __ ] absolute trash
so he's talking about georgia and how
the democrats were greedy
that they stole two seats in georgia
what
okay
he's talking about the runoff not not
that not the actual the the general
election he's talking about the runoff
election
where warnock and ossoff won
now the same people who voted for ossoff
voted during that same time on the same
ballot
as warnock like they voted on the same
[ __ ] ballot there wasn't two ballots
there was one ballot with both their
names on it so the people who got a
ballot or who wanted to get a ballot and
wanted to vote they had the opportunity
to vote for both senators at the same
god damn time
do you does this guy not know how
[ __ ] elections work did he not go
vote
does he not vote did has he never seen a
[ __ ] ballot
of course the democrats won both seats
the democrats were going to win both
seats are the republicans were going to
win both seats
and trump made sure that
trump made sure that in at the end of
december in the beginning of january
the [ __ ] is this guy talking about we
got greedy listen
the next time us libtards cheat are all
you liptards listening out there because
i got a message for you
the next time we decide to cheat why
don't we go ahead and get 60 senators
let's do that that way we can overturn
the filibuster and and and give a bunch
of liberal libtard stuff to the entire
country
you know crazy radical things like
universal health care
make sure
people have a a decent [ __ ] wage you
know crazy radical stuff
get the actual [ __ ] out of here